LARRY PAUL ARNN: It's
my honor to introduce
to you a great man.
That's a habit, because I got
to also introduce Natasha--
not a great man, a great woman.
Richard Corcoran is the
Florida Education Commissioner
and has purview
over K through 12.
He's one of the best in the
country at his job, which
is not quite damning
with faint praise,
because there's two or
three that are pretty good.
His wife is a classical
education woman herself
and a mother of six.
His father was a soldier, and
he was in the Army Reserve.
The cool thing about
him, in my opinion,
is that I learned
about six years ago--
because we got into education
reform and founding charter
schools.
And the best place in the
country to do it is Florida.
And I started learning
how that came to be.
First I met a man named
Michael Bileca, who was
Speaker of the Florida House.
And then I met our speaker
today, who Michael Bileca--
did you succeed Michael
or did he succeed you?
I see.
They were in the Florida
House at the same time.
And then, of course,
the great Ron DeSantis--
and they have been step-by-step
reforming the charter school
laws and in Florida
so that you can do it.
And there are a lot of detailed
things that have to be done,
like charter schools
are public schools.
They have a measure
of independence
from the government, and
how wide that measure is
the decisive factor.
But also, when does the
education money come
to the school, and
in what quantity
so you can actually do it?
And they just have
been working on that
and figuring it out and
coming to see that for years.
And they have made Florida a
paradise for charter education.
And they're still working on it.
I was impressed more
than anything else
about the acts of
friendship that
have gone on that have kept
continuity in that effort,
because that's very
difficult stuff to do--
to stand up against the constant
bureaucratization of everything
in the country, to
try to liberate people
to do wonderful jobs like
running schools and raising
their own children--
that is, in the short term,
often a thankless task.
And it takes a lot of
skill and commitment,
and it's rare to see people
who sustain that together
for so long.
And that's what's
happened in Florida.
And we're going to hear about
whatever Richard Corcoran wants
to say, but I will
say that he is
one of the most important men
in the United States today,
and we are honored
to have him here.
Richard Corcoran.
RICHARD CORCORAN: First, I
want to say it's a great honor
to be at Hillsdale College.
Obviously, being a
conservative all my life,
Hillsdale has played
an active role
in whether it's just the
monthly Imprimis or people I've
known who come to Hillsdale,
watching the speakers--
it's a fantastic college.
And you guys, we've been
here two days-- just
fantastic meetings with
the faculty, with Dr. Arnn.
So it's a pleasure to be here.
I'll give you one warning,
though, before I start.
And when you're
Speaker of the House
and then become Education
Commissioner, you get invited.
And so I was invited
to go to a nursing home
and give a speech on
American exceptionalism.
And so I thought,
OK, I'll do that.
And they had all the residents
gathered, and I give a speech
and talked about
American exceptionalism.
And then the director
said there was
one gentleman who was too sick.
He couldn't make
it out of his room,
and he asked if you'd be kind
enough to give him a speech.
And so I thought, OK.
So I went into his
room, and I gave--
of course I shortened it,
and I gave him the speech.
And I'm trying to say
all these important lines
about American
exceptionalism, and he just
won't even look at me,
won't budge, won't move.
I say another one.
Nothing.
I get done with the speech.
And so finally as I'm
walking to the door,
I think I've got to say
something to this gentleman.
And so I turn to
him, and I said,
sir, I really, really
hope you get better.
And he kind of
pops up in his bed,
and he goes, I hope you do, too.
[LAUGHTER]
So I always like to warn
an audience before I speak,
because now you've
been fairly warned.
I do want to talk,
though, a little bit,
which at this college, you guys
could lecture ad nauseum me
on the topic.
But I grew up with two parents.
My parents were older.
Both have passed.
Both had very difficult lives.
My dad was orphaned
when he was two--
grew up in orphanages and foster
homes, went into World War II,
and then after World War II
got into the Foreign Service.
My mother grew up in England
during the Great Depression.
Their family went
through the entire crash.
They had no money,
and so her father
took a job managing a
tea plantation in India,
and that's where she was
actually born-- in Darjeeling.
And so but they grew up,
and so they would always
say to us in these two
pivotal moments in time--
the Great Depression
and World War II.
And so all we would ever hear
was, philosophy was everything.
You ought to have a philosophy.
What is your philosophy?
And it could be anything.
If you're thinking
about having children,
what's your philosophy on how--
what do they look like at 18?
What's your philosophy on work?
What's your philosophy
in all aspects of life?
That philosophy was
everything, and it
was because their lives were
completely altered, changed,
and controlled by the
philosophies of others,
both economically
and physically.
And so they would say,
either you have a philosophy
or you don't, but if
you don't, that's OK,
but someone else has one,
and you will absolutely
be moved by their philosophy.
And so all of that just
spawned that rich thought
throughout-- we would literally
have conversations and say,
is man good or bad?
We would have to
answer that question.
And then when I became
a Speaker later in life,
these philosophies
start coming together.
And you realize that--
I will tell you,
the best legislators
that I would serve
with, the ones
who really understood
the role of government
and what it means to be a
successful self-governing
society, would be
ones that would
say that man was inherently bad
as opposed to inherently good.
The ones who were
inherently good
were the ones who would
constantly come up
with a great society
and everything
along those lines on a
microcosm at a state level.
So getting the
position of education,
the first thing I
thought of was what
is the philosophy of education?
And the sad truth--
many of them conservatives--
how many times will we
hear we need more welders
than philosophers?
What is the purpose
of education?
And the modern day--
even among Republican
rank and file--
version of education is it's
a means to a job, a career,
or something along those lines.
And it's so much more.
And I didn't even know
this until I spent time
with Dr. Arnn today.
But obviously, one
of my favorite folks
that I followed throughout
time is Frederick Douglass,
and I did not know he had
been on this campus twice
and have tremendous
statues and quotes
and what have you about
Frederick Douglass.
But he has the greatest
quote of education.
When I took over as
Education Commissioner,
the first thing I did
was tear down most
of the stuff in the building.
And I put up huge
quotes, one by Washington
and one by Frederick Douglass.
Because I thought
I wanted everyone
who walked into the
building to understand
what the philosophy and the
purpose of education was.
But he has this just fantastic
quote I'll paraphrase,
where he says,
education is freedom.
This is a guy who escaped
slavery, came to the north.
He goes education is freedom.
It's emancipation.
It is the uplifting
of the human soul
to the glorious light of truth.
And to deny any individual
a world-class education
is the greatest crime
against humanity.
And so when you think about
what education is-- and again,
nobody knows it better
than Hillsdale--
but it is about
creating great citizens.
You look at the
Fortune 500 CEOs,
and they all say, we want
people who can critically
think, who can problem
solve, who can communicate.
We really don't care
what their degree's in.
I always quote Steve Jobs,
because people look at me like,
oh, you're just a
liberal arts guy.
You don't really understand
the role of STEM in society.
And I say, OK, well, let's
take the first trillion dollar
company in America-- is Apple.
The CEO of Apple-- also educated
in a liberal arts school
for the time he was there--
where he found
Helvetica text, and that
became the formation of
the Apple computer text.
They said to him,
how did you become
the first trillion
dollar company?
And he would say, it
was easy because all
the other companies--
Microsoft, Oracle,
name them all--
they're computer
science companies.
And this is on YouTube.
They're computer
science companies.
He says, Apple-- we exist at
the intersection of computer
science and liberal arts.
This I can teach you, and I
probably would rather do it.
I'd rather not have to
detox you from whatever
you learned in college
or wherever you're from.
This, I can't teach.
Either you have it or you don't.
And that's why everything--
you look at Apple.
Everything they did--
every advertisement--
it was never about selling
computers, to the point
now that you have guys who have
become millionaires writing
books about Steve Jobs' why.
But he's literally
just saying that this
is the why that Steve Jobs
had about the liberal arts
and computer science
intersection.
But what it did was he
would sell think different.
It's going to change your life--
his famous commercial
about we're the crazy ones.
You can't ignore us.
You can't-- narrated
by Richard Dreyfuss.
It was this whole
concept of, as Dr. Arnn
was saying earlier--
it's the true, the good,
and the beautiful.
And that's what built him
to this beautiful trillion
dollar company.
And so all of that
gets to the two
points I do want to
impress upon you as I
got to the department-- is that
now you know the philosophy.
You know the one
thing that we can
do to change people's lives.
We talked about it last night.
We can't force everyone to be
raised in a two-parent home,
but we know the consequences
or the derivative
of that is just enormous.
But what we can do,
and what we are doing,
is trying to give every child
that world-class education--
help them become good citizens,
good spouses, good community
leaders, and recognize the
inherent value in education.
But we're not there.
And not only are
we not there, we
struggle more and more
and more to get there.
And so I'll give you
the facts in Florida.
And on the National Assessment
of Educational Progress, which
all the states take,
we're in the top 4
for reading in fourth grade.
The number one is Massachusetts.
Pretty perennially.
I think it's going to
change as a result of COVID,
because we're the only
state that opened up
our schools-- face-to-face
instruction to any child who
wanted it.
Boston is still closed.
And so, but Massachusetts
is number one.
They're number one, and they're
like 45% on the NAEP exam
at or above basic.
Which means I always say 55%--
the number one state
and the richest country
in the history of mankind--
the number one state
has 55%, give or take--
Florida, we're like at
39, so we're over 60%--
of our fourth graders that
are somewhat, partially,
or fully illiterate.
And so now take Florida.
We have our own state assessment
we give in third grade.
In our third grade
assessment, we basically
have similar numbers--
42%, 44% of our third
graders in English
are either partially
fully illiterate.
They're either
getting 1s and 2s.
And when you have
that, what you're doing
in a society is not only
are you creating people
who have no concept of what
it means to self govern or be
a citizen--
they have no hope.
And the most dangerous person
in any realm of society--
in life, in a school
yard, wherever, it
doesn't matter-- take hope
away from a human being,
and they become extremely,
extremely dangerous.
And I think you see
that play itself out.
And so how do you move that?
I say to my staff
all the time, we
ought to just send letters
to every single third grade
parent, which is
literally 55% of them,
and say, hey, dear Mrs. Jones.
Billy's a great kid.
Enjoyed having him in class.
But here's the bottom line--
there's no hope for him.
He's toast.
There's nothing we can do.
Because we know this fact, too.
If you're a 1 and
2 in third grade--
because we had 20 years of
accountability history--
then I asked my staff, give me
every single graduate of third
grade that became
a tenth grader--
because now we have
20 years of history--
and tell me what they
were in 10th grade
the last time we
give the ESA exam.
And guess what?
86% who are 1s and
2s-- either partially
or functionally illiterate--
are partially or functionally
illiterate in 10th grade.
And the only thing
that changes them--
obviously Hillsdale is
a significant factor--
if they move to some other--
the three things that
changed education in America
are accountability, number
one-- more than anything else.
Choice number two-- but if
they somehow find their way
into a Choice school-- an
excellent Choice school--
if they somehow find
an excellent teacher--
maybe they get a seventh
grade middle school Hillsdale
graduate who says--
and what they're
going to do is they're
going to go back and start
like at kindergarten, first,
and second grade and get
those children caught up.
But otherwise, 86% are still
functionally illiterate.
The converse is true.
If you're a 3, 4,
or 5, it's about 85%
are still 3s, 4s, and 5s.
So whatever happens between
pre-K or birth and third
grade--
once we lose them there,
we lose them for life.
And they become, what I
would say is not all of them,
but a lot of them become
very, very dangerous.
And that's a problem.
And so how do you fix it?
What we have done in Florida,
and moving to do in Florida, is
we're going all in.
The stats are just-- as you
dig into it more and more,
the stats are staggering.
61% of low income
kids don't have
a single book in their home.
And if they don't have a
single book in their home,
no one's reading to them.
If you're a parent,
most of you guys
have probably read to your
children at least 20 minutes
a day, but that's the
minimal goal we try to say--
20 minutes a day.
If you read 20 minutes
a day to your child,
they finish in the top
10%, statistically,
on standardized tests.
If you read 1 minute a day to
your child or no minutes a day
to your child,
they basically are
the corpus of your
dropouts, your failures,
and/or your
illiterate population.
And so if we don't go all in and
wrestle with those kids in that
pre-K to third grade realm-- we
were talking the other night,
and I said, if I was to do
something else much like
Hillsdale is doing--
I'd love to see the
same Hillsdale model,
but to rapidly expand and
go into pre-K to third grade
and going into
every single state
as fast as we can in
a big way, because we
know that once we lose
them in third grade,
we lose them for life.
So that's-- we're
doing everything.
We're trying to
do at Peace Corps
and have great graduates
like Hillsdale go in
and read to these kids
from pre-K to third grade.
We're having literally
a book a month club.
These kids are very poor.
They've never had it.
I know for me, when I get
the Amazon truck pull in,
and I know it's a new
golf club or something,
I'm pretty excited.
So imagine a child who doesn't
even celebrate Christmas now
having a book delivered to
his house on a daily basis.
And that book is
tied to our standards
that we completely rewrote,
and it's content rich.
And so not only are they
getting that great literature,
they're learning the
same book in school
at the same time
with their mentors--
all at the same time.
And hopefully it will
have that effect.
We've also basically gone all
in on the science of reading.
Modern day-- we all recognize
that the social experiment
of whole language was
an abject failure.
But even now we don't
call it whole language.
Now we have great terms--
blended literacy, whatever.
But it's up and down in our
schools all across America--
not obviously in
Hillsdale charter schools
or any classical
school for that matter.
But if we don't
have that phonics,
and the phonemic awareness, and
the literacy, and the fluency,
and the vocabulary, you're never
going to get the comprehension.
And so we're going all in and
fighting with our publishers
that we will not have a single
textbook in a classroom that
doesn't have the
science of reading.
Hopefully, all of
that stuff and we'll
start seeing
quickly improvements
in our students' education.
So I know that it sounds--
as an aside to
that, I'll tell you.
Having been in the
legislature, it's
an amazing thing in education.
And you guys have seen it
as you go into other states.
But when I was in the
legislature, if somebody
came before-- and I was on
an environmental committee--
and they said, hey, we
have this magic potion.
We can drop it in
Lake Okeechobee,
and immediately there'll
be no blue-green algae.
There would be absolute outcry.
People would be upset.
They'd almost be thrown
out of the committee.
This is ridiculous.
We would have to study that
for six or seven years.
We'd want to make sure
everything was done correctly
and all our scientific
data was correct.
This will never happen in
the next six or seven years.
Now conversely, go to
an education committee,
and somebody comes in and says,
we have this magic potion.
If we put it in
schools tomorrow,
our kids will just be
phenomenal students.
There like, let's try it.
I mean, there's no screening
or testing or anything,
to the point that when you look
at America on the national--
where we compete with
the rest of the world--
America, we're like 24th,
28th, and like 35th and math,
science, and in English--
you know, just abysmal.
But when they did the study
and they looked at what does
America do great, the
just wonderful irony--
which we still do today--
the two things that
America-- everyone
says nobody can compete
with-- number one
is we have the
prettiest buildings.
And so to quote, you can
teach Plato under a tree.
We don't even teach Plato, but
we have a beautiful building.
So don't worry about
going under the tree
and learning something.
And then the second
part is that we
have absolutely without
question more tech in classrooms
than anybody else.
And it's been, quite frankly,
overwhelmingly a failure,
not a success.
And so those are the two
things we score well,
even though we're
24th, 28th, and 29th.
All of that to say,
my dad and mom--
I'll start with them.
I do think there's optimism.
I was talking a lot
to Dr. Arnn about it
with the universities
and colleges,
and we have a whole
group of folks
that are boards of directors
from Flagler College trying
to-- how do you replicate
what Hillsdale has done?
Is it possible and
can it be sustainable
and all of those questions?
And Dr. Arnn basically
said, quoting Churchill,
but there is hope.
They're formed on
a broken truth,
and so there is hope
for us to crash that.
And that's something my
father and mother would tell--
I don't know if
you've heard this,
but my dad would always say,
there's two little boys.
One's an eternal optimist, and
one's an eternal pessimist.
And so they go and they
get studied by doctors,
and they say let's put
the optimist boy in a room
with a pile of manure.
And let's take the
pessimist boy and put him
in a room with toys, candies,
and everything under the sun.
And they put the
boys in the room.
They check on them,
and they see the boy--
the pessimist-- first.
And they go in,
and he's cowering
in the corner of a room.
Like little boy, why aren't
you playing with the candy?
And he's like, I might get sick.
Why don't you play
with the toys--
I don't know, the buttons?
I could swallow a button.
It's like, OK.
That's a lost cause.
Let's go check on
the optimistic boy.
And they go check on
the optimistic boy,
and they look in the window,
and he's jumping up and down.
He's throwing the
manure everywhere.
It's on the ceiling.
It's all over his body.
They go rushing into the
room, and they're like,
whoa, whoa, whoa.
What are you doing?
Don't you it's a pile of manure?
And he goes, yeah, but
with all this manure,
there's got to be
a pony somewhere.
[LAUGHTER]
And so with that
analogy or anecdote
and with ending with
Frederick Douglass in that it
is far easier to raise
up healthy children
than it is to fix broken men--
another Frederick Douglass
quote.
But the pony in
the story is what
you guys are doing--
what Hillsdale
is doing, what all
of you are doing--
educating the educators who
will be in those schools.
It will hopefully
change our country
and sustain us for
another 230 years--
at least that's the hope.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you,
Commissioner Corcoran.
We now have time for some
Q&A. If you have a question,
please raise your hand
and wait for a microphone
to be brought to you.
AUDIENCE: Terrific talk.
So I'm on the board of Northwest
Ohio Classical Academy--
BCS High School,
opened two years ago.
Our outcomes are good,
and that is certainly
one of the motivations to
do the very heavy lift.
But the second motivation
is to encourage
others who may not necessarily
want a particularly
classical education from
the Barney Charter School.
To see them make good choices--
is there any reason to believe
that that won't happen?
RICHARD CORCORAN: That--
SPEAKER: Even if they're not
at Barney Charter School,
we've got 24.
We've got 48 million
kids, K through 12.
We need to change.
There needs to be a vast
change in the education system
so our kids will prosper.
That's great.
That's the first motivation.
But the second
motivation is we're
hoping that others will make
some good choices where they're
not making it.
Are we having that effect?
Not necessarily in
Barney Charter School,
but just in Florida--
are you making--
do you see schools
changing for the better?
RICHARD CORCORAN: Absolutely,
but it's volatile.
So we just won a gubernatorial
race by 30,000 votes in a state
with 21 plus million people.
And flip that 30,000 votes--
I mean, if you followed Ron
DeSantis' opponent, Andrew
Gillum and what happened
to him afterwards.
I mean, we were that close.
And if Andrew Gillum
became the governor,
along comes Gwen Graham
and all of the radical left
and what they do to
our school system.
What we've had in
Florida that's worked,
and we've had numerous, whether
you go back to the DeSantis--
less than 1%, Rick Scott's
re-elect, less than 1%,
first election, less than 1%.
For whatever reason, we barely
win these governor's races,
but have won them since 1998.
So we've had a long run
of Republican governors
and a long run of reform.
So yes, when Governor
DeSantis gets elected,
he can immediately
say, OK, we're
going to eliminate common core.
We're going to
rewrite the standards.
We're going to make
them content rich.
We're going to have the
science of reading embedded
into in into our standards.
We're going to increase
accountability, increase
choice.
We just got done Friday
from the legislative session
and passed another--
1.2 million kids are eligible
for Choice in Florida.
So it happens, but I will tell
you leadership is everything.
And as soon as that
leadership changes,
everything else does
too, unfortunately.
But that's the reality.
McChrystal would say, I
have all these colonels.
I have 20 of them.
I could take the best
colonel with the best
troop and the worst colonel
with the worst troop
and I could switch them.
And immediately,
the best colonel
is going to have the best
troop and the worst colonel's
going to have the worst troop.
And it's the same-- and
that's not as ideological.
But in the world that
we live in education,
it's 100% ideological.
So in no time--
what we have to do is cross the
Rubicon, and we're very close.
I would say the three
things that have changed
education are accountability--
has absolutely.
The second we
flipped on the lights
and a parent became aware that
because I like the teacher,
she was very nice, the
principal was nice, [INAUDIBLE]
functioned well, and
I dropped my kid off,
and they seemed to be learning.
They were bringing
back work packets.
And then all of a sudden
we flip on the light
and say that's an F school,
immediately change happened.
And people became
frustrated and angry.
And so that's really changed
Florida more than anything.
Second was just this
advancement of Choice.
So we have about 3
million school children.
If we can ever get to
1.5 across that Rubicon--
we're probably there now with
about half a million children
in Choice, because we can't--
even if you had a Gwen Graham
or Andrew Gillum or whoever come
in-- a Nancy Pelosi in Florida--
you can't take
those 500,000 kids
and bring them back into
the public school system.
So you have to keep
doing what we're doing
as quickly as we're doing it.
Dr. Arnn was talking
about Tennessee
asking for 100 Barney
Charter Schools.
That's a game changer.
Once you have that,
and all of a sudden
the governor leaves
who's fantastic--
Governor Lee's gone and it's a
liberal that comes in there--
you can't put the
animals back in the barn.
So yeah, it's
happening, but it only
happens when the
leadership is good.
Where the leadership
is bad, I mean,
all you have to do is read
the articles under a pandemic.
I don't care.
Take the top 10, five
largest urban districts--
school districts in the
United States of America.
Florida has five.
All five of ours were open
with face-to-face instruction
for all children.
The other five were closed--
most of them until
January or February.
And some are still
closed today--
Boston, Chicago, Los Angeles.
It's still-- you're never
getting those kids back.
You're never getting
those kids back.
And so but why?
I mean, it's the difference
between Gavin Newsom and Ron
DeSantis.
You know, Cuomo
was writing books
about how to survive
in a pandemic
while arguably 10,000
senior citizens died because
of his failures, while
Ron DeSantis was studying
the science and the metrics
and the first thing he did
was protect the nursing homes.
Leadership's everything.
So yes, under good leadership
we're making great strides.
SPEAKER: Question in the back.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, sir.
One thing I've
wondered-- it seems
like a very ideological
debate that we're
having, and maybe
not always connected
to outcomes in a beneficial way.
And it appears that
quite frequently it's
hard to find common ground.
What have you found to be a
good argument or a good way
to approach this discussion
that helps you find
common ground with people who
may have an adverse reaction
to your ideological position?
RICHARD CORCORAN:
I'm trying not to--
I grew up in an Irish
Catholic family with five,
so the dinner table was
always like arguments.
And the way I found common
ground is literally-- and Dr.
Arnn, again, was
talking about this--
I have fought.
The way I find common
ground-- because they
will roll over you.
When we wanted to open
up schools in September,
the entire agency
was surrounded.
We know we have a
small courtyard.
The entire agency was surrounded
by literally fake coffins,
headstones--
the grim reaper was walking
around the building.
And they sued me to
keep schools closed.
I think, I always
say I'm always open.
I'll sit down with anybody
and have that discussion.
I do think who I'm
describing, though--
I think if you're
talking about people--
can a Joe Biden sit down
and have a conversation
with a Tom Cotton?
Yes, I think they can.
But I'm talking on that
outer side, and really
its outer left.
There's no negotiation.
I don't think Antifa
wants to sit down and have
a conversation with me about how
can we make the society better.
And again, Dr. Arnn
gave a great analogy
about the warring in
the streets in Germany
pre-World War II was between
the Nazis and the Germans,
the communists.
And the Nazis ultimately won,
and Hitler became the leader
of the Nazi street fighters.
That's what I think
you're seeing with Antifa
and what have you.
What they want is
complete upheaval.
And so those people
I just don't--
where necessary
I'll sit with them,
but I think we have
to be efficient
and very strategic in how we
go about what we're doing.
And the war will be
won in education.
If we can get
education right, we
can have kids be literate
and then understand
what it means to be a
self-governing citizen
in a self-governing
country, we'll win it back.
I think Dr. Arnn, again--
I keep going-- we just
spent some time with him.
But he said that
education is our sword.
That's our weapon.
Our weapon is education.
And we can do it.
We can get it right.
And I do think--
I always try not
to sound biased,
but I do think that we
are willing to sit down.
We are willing to have
those conversations,
and we are willing to
look at the science.
All the far left yelling at
us about science, science,
science, but when it came
to opening up schools,
every single thing that has been
said in January and February
post the Biden
administration taking over
and the CDC and all the
changes, and now it's OK.
It's safe to open.
Kids don't transmit.
Kids aren't in harm's way.
All of that science was
100% available to us
in June and July, which is
what we made our decision on.
So I think we're willing to
have those conversations.
We're willing to be rational.
We're willing to look at
the science and the facts.
I mean, the truth is the truth.
This room believes in truth.
We believe it's objective.
I had lunch yesterday with
Janet and David Wayland,
and they were talking about how
they were educated in Kansas.
And I just thought
it was a great line.
But her professor used
to say all the time
to the doubters in the class as
they're going through learning
the great books.
And he would say, here's
what I'll tell you.
Fire is hot, water is
wet, and rocks are hard.
I mean, it's just
a beautiful way
of saying the
truth is the truth.
But they want to deny that.
I mean, the whole argument
on university campuses--
there is no truth.
It's all subjective.
And so there's going
to be a battle.
And so sit down,
have that discussion,
be transparent, be open always.
I think all of us would do that.
But the way we're going to get
to where we're going to get
is by fighting every
step of the way.
It will be a battle, and
we will have to fight.
And as Winston Churchill
says, all the other virtues
are great, but courage
is the most important,
because without it, none
of the others are possible.
SPEAKER: Question to
the speaker's left.
LANA THEIS: Hi, State
Senator Lana Theis up here.
Hi.
RICHARD CORCORAN: Hi.
LANA THEIS: Thank
you for being here.
So grateful.
Michigan has lost 65,000 kids
from our public education
system, largely because
of the shutdown.
I'm wondering-- excuse me--
if Florida experienced any kind
of a loss, and what that looked
like.
Since you stayed open, I would
assume probably not, but more
than the normal loss.
RICHARD CORCORAN: We track that.
And I'm just talking
students, because we have,
as Michigan does, how
we do our funding form,
there's weights
for certain things.
So one student could actually
count for two students,
just based on the
weights and funding.
But if you look at
actual students,
there was maybe a 5,000
or 10,000 difference.
And a lot of them, when
we tracked them down--
because we were awarded the
districts for tracking them
down--
most of them were parents who
went to the homeschooling mode
without properly
withdrawing their child.
So it comes up as an extra
10,000 lost students,
but we found that most of them
were home school students.
But every year we lose
10,000 to 15,000 students.
We are a growth state.
1,000 people come pretty
much every single day.
But we also have a lot
of families leaving,
especially when we have
a Hurricane Michael come
through the panhandle.
You'll see a lot of the
low income families will
go to Alabama or Mississippi.
And so we always
have that, but we
do a good job of tracking them.
And because we were
open, it was easier
to do so, because
basically if 95 kids came
back to a class or a school
we knew that was supposed
to be 100, we could
immediately know here's
the five we've got to find.
It makes it a lot easier
when you're tracking them.
As opposed to-- I mean,
look at Los Angeles.
They have online, synchronous
learning, asynchronous--
they've tried everything.
And I think there's some days
where only like 15% or 20%
of the students are
actually clicking in online.
I mean, it's just a disaster.
I've said to people,
it's not sad.
It's not frustrating.
What's going on in the rest
of the country is criminal.
If I was to go to any one of
your homes, and grab your kids,
and put them in solitude,
and say they can't hang out
and they have to do
all of the stuff,
I'd be arrested for a
host of different crimes.
And then if I said to their
parents, and by the way,
you're going to have to close
down your small business.
You can't work anymore
because you're going have
to take care of your kids--
I'd be arrested for
a host of crimes.
What's going on in the
rest of the country
is literally criminal taking
and criminal behavior.
SPEAKER: There's a question
to the speaker's left.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My question regards
the curriculum
and what role the
state has, if any,
in oversight of local
school curriculums.
And I have a little story
that I'd like to insert here.
Two Thanksgivings ago, we
had a family celebration,
and I found out that
there were going
to be two children--
one 8, one 10 attending.
So my husband and I thought
it would be really cute--
I have these costumes--
to dress up as pilgrims.
We thought that the kids--
when we opened the door they
saw two pilgrims, and
it was Thanksgiving--
that they'd get a
kick out of it, right?
So we kept the costumes
on for the entire day.
So we're sitting around the
table in our pilgrim costumes.
My husband had a hat.
I had my little--
And finally, the 10-year-old
at one point looked at us and--
because I'm starting to give
the story of the Indians
and the Pilgrims and
the meal and the Indians
really helped out the
pilgrims because it
was the first winter.
I give the whole spiel
that we grew up with.
And this 10-year-old
looks at me, and he says,
didn't the pilgrims come to
kill the Indigenous people?
I mean, talk about putting
a damper on things.
So there we were
dressed as pilgrims,
and in the eyes of
this little boy,
he had learned that
the pilgrims came
to kill the Indigenous Indians.
So we tried to set
things straight,
but then we changed the topic.
And the mother
went, well you know,
they do go to a
progressive school.
And I said, well,
I was just shocked
to find out-- to even
hear the word Indigenous
in the mouth of a 10-year-old.
You know, why would he say
they came to kill the Indians?
I said, it sounds to me
like your progressive school
is indoctrinating.
And that was the end, and
then we just kind of moved on.
So then I found out
about the 1619 Project
that I had never
heard of before.
So all these years, our children
have been reading books--
being taught books--
that present things
a certain way.
And I bet you that a
good majority of parents
are totally unaware.
Oh, and by the way, they didn't
know what the Mayflower was.
Because I got into the
boat-- they came over
on this boat, the Mayflower.
No, we haven't heard
about the Mayflower.
OK, so how are you addressing--
and that's just one example.
Critical race theory
is another one that's
permeated our curriculum.
Who decides what books are
going to be used in instruction?
RICHARD CORCORAN:
That's a great question.
So we've just
fought that battle,
and we still fight
it on a daily basis.
And there's multiple
ways you can fight it.
So first, we rewrote
all our standards.
So we're on a standard
five-year book adoption,
or seven-year book
adoption, depending if you
add in certain science years.
And so we disrupted
the whole book adoption
because we rewrote
our whole standards.
And we rewrote them with
the science of reading.
We have the first
in the nation--
a civics reading list
from kindergarten
all the way through 12th grade.
We have a reading list
for all other courses.
It's just content rich,
and the quick anecdote,
which you guys know well--
I probably stole it from
you guys when you came.
But they have basically
kids who are 1s and 2s who
are functionally or
somewhat illiterate,
and they have the
3s, 4s, and 5s.
And they put them in a
room, and they give them
a reading comprehension
exam, and it's on baseball.
All of the 1s and
2s play baseball.
None of the 3s, 4s,
and 5s play baseball.
And then they grade
and see how they did
on the reading comprehension.
And the 1s and 2s scored 4-0,
40% higher than the 3s, 4s,
and 5s, even though they
couldn't read nearly
as fast or as well or at all.
But they understood the game.
And so obviously
content matters.
The vocabulary matters
as much as the decoding.
And so we rewrote
all of our standards.
We did all of that stuff.
And then we do a
book adoption, which
now all the publishers,
and the publishers
are just infested with liberals.
And so we would have to say
to them in our bid specs,
we're not going
to take or approve
your bid unless you have--
a certain percentage
of our reading list
has to be in your text.
You can have no whole
language or blended literacy
or anything, and it has to
be the science of reading.
And we went through
a whole criteria.
And then when the books came
in, we evaluate the books
on the criteria we said.
But I was just saying last night
to the folks that we had dinner
with, so now the
books have come back.
And you don't think--
and, of course, COVID hit, so
we were a little bit distracted.
But I didn't think
to say, OK, keep all
of the crazy liberal stuff out.
And so now we
literally have them,
and they hide it in
social emotional learning.
So it doesn't say
critical race theory,
but you could definitely
have a teacher who
teaches critical race theory.
So now we have to go
back to them and say,
if it's electronic,
we want it out.
And then on top of
that, we're passing
a rule this coming month that
says for the 185,000 teachers,
you can't indoctrinate
students with stuff
that's not based
on our standards--
the new best standards.
So all of that, but you have to
police them on a daily basis.
It's 185,000 teachers in
a classroom with anywhere
from 18 to 25 kids, and if
you're not physically there
in the classroom--
I will tell you, it's
working in the universities,
and it's starting to work in--
I've censored or fired or
terminated numerous teachers
for doing that.
I'm getting sued right
now in Duval County, which
is Jacksonville,
because there was
an entire classroom memorialized
to Black Lives Matter.
We made sure she was
terminated, and now we're
being sued by every one
of the liberal left groups
for freedom of speech issues.
And I say to them-- to the
point of your question--
try to find common ground.
I'll say, look, let's
not even talk about
whether it's right
or true or good--
what you have there.
My issue is when you're
a third grade teacher
and only 42%, 41% of your
kids are on grade level,
why don't you do me a favor?
Get them on grade level and
then we'll have that discussion.
Make them at least to be able to
read and understand it first--
to try to not act
like I'm radical right
or whatever they
want to call me,
but it's a constant
vigilant fight.
It's a terrible battle.
SPEAKER: We now have time
for one last question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you for
coming all the way from sunny
and free Florida
to join us here.
RICHARD CORCORAN: Yesterday,
you rivaled Florida.
AUDIENCE: The weather
followed you here.
Dr. Arnn often talks
about education
being a partnership between
the educators and the parents.
We've had this huge
influx of federal cash.
What are some steps that Florida
is taking to help partner
with parents and
empower parents,
specifically with some of
the federal money that's
been coming in?
RICHARD CORCORAN: We've taken
most of the federal money that
wasn't--
they've gotten more prescriptive
in the last ARP plan.
But before that,
we basically have
been using it to
invest on that pre-K
all the way to third grade in
massive ways involving parents.
And then on top of that, trying
to grab hold of the learning
gain losses that we have
and the learning gap.
I mean, in Florida we have--
so I asked my staff--
right now on the third grade
FSA, we're at about 58%
3s, 4s, and 5s, 42% below--
partially or fully illiterate.
Which I say that, because one
or two just doesn't-- it sounds
innocuous.
I want you to understand these
kids are never coming out
of that for the most part.
And then I said, OK, if I wanted
to at the current growth rate--
we are absolutely--
if you go to any
of these national
conferences, they'll
tell you Florida leads the
country in education reform.
And what we're doing,
most other states copy.
And most stats-- we have the
number one AP test takers.
We have the number
two performance.
And this is all pre-COVID.
I think you're going to
see us go to number one
in most categories
because of our kids
having that instruction.
But besides that-- so Florida
doing well in reform--
what would it take at
our current growth rate,
because we started at way below.
I used to joke.
It's a terrible thing.
I hope I don't offend
anyone for Mississippi.
But I used to joke, thank
God for back in 1998--
thank God there was
Mississippi, otherwise we'd
be dead last in every category.
But Mississippi was, I think,
dead last in everything.
But what would it do to
close the achievement gap?
And what would it take to get
non-Title I or non-low income
kids to 90% proficiency
in third grade?
And what would it take for
Title I or low income kids
to get to 90% proficiency
by third grade?
And the staggering number
is to take basically
two parent, middle
class and up kids--
to get them from
their current state
to 90% proficiency in
Florida would take 100 years.
It would take 200 years to
get low income kids there.
And the overwhelming problem--
I mean, there is an
organized injustice
that's going on in education,
with basically our problem is
low income kids.
And with all the
Barney schools, you're
starting to see the classical
schools get more and more
of these low income kids--
to your question, sir, that
now it's going to really help.
I mean, we're going into
the nontraditional sector
of these students.
And so what you're
seeing, though,
with that huge chasm is unless
you have just complete Clayton
Christensen disruption,
you're going
to have this organized
injustice, which
really is this--
I say it not publicly, but
the bulk of those low income
kids are majority minority.
And these are our
struggling readers.
Our struggling readers are
overwhelming majority poor.
Of that poor population,
overwhelming majority minority.
Of that population,
overwhelmingly majority
African-American.
So there is an injustice
that's going on.
Instead of having marches
and riots and what have you,
there's something that could be
done, but it's not being done.
But the more we
empower those parents--
And what we found in
the Choice movement,
people would
literally say to us--
when we started the
Transformation on Choice back
in 1998, they'd be, you can't.
Literally, these would be things
that the left would say to us.
You can't do that.
You can't just
turn over a voucher
and give it to a single
mom who doesn't even
have a job or an education.
It would be a disaster.
They would literally
say that to us--
I mean, a patently
racist statement.
And yet when we did
that, what we found
is guess what every parent does?
Every parent cares about their
kids far more than a bureaucrat
sitting in some administration
building in city hall.
And they do care, and they
do move with their feet
to the point that the charter
school movement in Florida--
I can't say this for the
rest of the country--
we have more minority students
in our public charter schools
than we do in our
traditional schools.
And we have the same
and sometimes higher
low income kids in
our charter schools
than we do in our
traditional public schools.
And all are public.
Because parents
will get involved,
and they will make a difference.
And the results are
anywhere from 10 to 15--
on a bad day-- better than in
the traditional public schools.
So we know that the more
you involve those parents,
you will have better
outcomes for the students.
AUDIENCE: Please join me in
thanking Commissioner Corcoran.
RICHARD CORCORAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]